- Joshua, have y'all met before?
- Nice to meet you, no.
- We have not.
- It's nice to meet you too.
- I like that we all got the vibe.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was
like, somebody gave us
the little bit of 70s influence.
- I was almost gonna wear those shoes.
I'm glad I chose these instead.
- These are J.Lo's shoes.
- [Joshua] Her actual shoes?
- Well, she has a new line.
Her shoe line.
So they're JLO by J.Lo.
- Do you know what I like about
them is that they're not...
Like, it's a pretend heel.
Like, it's like it's a platform.
I love a platform because
it's raised up already.
- Yeah, and it's very easy to walk in
so you can borrow them anytime.
- [Kelly] Way easier than stilettos, yeah.
You wouldn't know because you're a man.
Anyway, so, I mean, I'm
not bitter about it.
- It's okay, I'll just
move one more seat over.
- Just kidding, no.
This is your first talk show, right?
- Yes, this is my first one!
- [Kelly] I didn't know! That's exciting!
(audience applauds)
Do you remember your first talk show?
- The first talk show that
I remember being on is TRL,
which some people-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Christine] I loved TRL.
- [Kelly] I was on TRL.
I've been around for that long, yeah.
- I called in to TRL.
- But we're going like
25 years ago now.
But it was a lot more
anxiety-inducing than this.
I'm just gonna say.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, they
would scream so loud.
Everybody and you're in this
small little room, yeah.
- I would fight over
Backstreet Boys and *NSYNC
winning the top spot.
- I think we were there
honestly with *NSYNC or...
Yeah, I think we were there with *NSYNC.
- [Christine] I would've died.
- So as you can imagine, it was-
- [Christine] Thank God I'm
meeting you years later.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, the decibel of-
- Because wouldn't have kept my cool.
- Yeah, the frequency of scream.
That's interesting.